dañado pero no completamente destruido
el puente de clichó un hito de cristal
en el centro de kiev se encuentra vacío
y desolado este puente peatonal lleva el
nombre del alcalde de la ciudad vitaly
en este video él se grabe en el lugar
inspeccionando las consecuencias del
ataque
dañado por los bárbaros el cristal está
dañado
pues cobros aquí fragmentos de misiles
cristales rotos por todas partes
no hay daño realmente significativos
aquí pero hay un cráter abajo hay un
cráter es increíble que nadie por aquí
haya resultado herido
los ataques se produjeron en represalia
a lo que el presidente Putin calificó de
ataque terrorista ucraniano contra el
puente de crimea un enlace de suministro
crítico entre Rusia y la Península
anexionada Putin afirmó que su objetivo
era una infraestructura militar y
energética clave pero en kiev el puente
Atlixco no tiene ninguna importancia
militar significativa y sigue siendo un
símbolo de la resistencia ucraniana en
las calles de kiev se está retirando los
fragmentos de cristal y las ventanas
rotas mientras los residentes limpian en
la ciudad tras los atentados del lunes
en su discurso nocturno el presidente
celenski no se dejó intimidar ni
desanimar por los ataques
ahora los ocupantes no pueden oponerse a
nosotros en el campo de batalla y por
eso recurren a este terror Pues bien
hagamos el campo de batalla aún más
doloroso para el enemigo restauraremos
todo lo que fue
destruidona decenas murieron y otras
tantas resultaron heridas en los
atentados perpetrados en todo el país
pero esto no marca en absoluto el final
ya que Putin promete represalias más
severas